negotiations for a new global climate
change deal are to be finalized at the
Paris conference in December 2015 and
one thing is clear to keep planetary
warming below two degrees centigrade the
richest countries will need to increase
their financial efforts to help
developing countries cut emissions and
adapt to the consequences of climate
change the EU and its member states are
already the largest contributors to
climate finance worldwide at least
twenty percent of EU spending until 2020
has been earmarked for climate related
activities the EU is scaling up
contributions towards the joint
international target of 100 billion US
dollars per year by 2020 to support
climate action in developing countries
but efforts need to be shared in a fair
way amongst developed countries
mobilizing contributions from different
sources promoting green investments
taxing carbon emissions and phasing out
fossil fuel subsidies are all part of
the EU strategy to tackle climate change
but coordinated international action on
climate finance is necessary come out of
the Paris conference with a solid deal
and help developing countries step up
the fight against climate change
you